tomorrow on the show we're going to
spend some time talking about the overt
christian nationalist movement and the
republican party now
is overtly christian nationalist they're
they're straight up saying we're sick of
this separation of church and state
stuff we're sick of all of it
uh but i want to give you another data
point in this today before we do our
bigger story on it tomorrow marjorie
taylor green among others spoke at the
turning point usa event over the weekend
we're going to look at more clips of
this we'll look at trump's speech and
don jr speech and lauren bo bear saying
i never was an escort i never was a
prostitute for ted cruz really weird
weird event but before we get into that
in more detail there was this one moment
where marjorie taylor green said
christian nationalism is great that's
what we need uh let's take a look at
this video clip and then we'll discuss
perfect it just means we're doing the
right thing
and i think that's what the republican
party needs to be about
i'm a christian how many christians do
we have here
so you see i also call myself a
christian nationalist
and that's not a bad word
that's actually a good thing right and
there's nothing wrong with leading with
your in with your faith because we
should lead with our faith because if
we're doing that then we're doing the
right thing doesn't mean we're perfect
it just means we're doing the right
thing so she says that that's what the
republican party should be about now
christian nationalism is not just
we happen to be christian and
we like the united states or whatever
christian nationalism means you believe
united states as a nation
is defined by christianity
government should be actively
keeping the united states a christian
nation
uh the united states government should
be imposing or prioritizing or giving
preference to christianity there should
be
christianity should be the doctrine a
prescriptive doctrine for how the
government runs and you're sort of
breaking down separation of church and
state this is not unique to marjorie
taylor greene that the belief that
christianity should be privileged in the
public square remember we've looked at
clips of lauren bobert lauren bobert
openly is calling for the same thing now
and i believe that great patriots all
throughout this nation
and christians will begin to position
themselves
in these days and these times the
pastors would have a boldness to speak
from the pulpit of their churches to
direct and inform the church on how to
influence the direction of government so
that's pretty full on and if that's not
direct enough for you here she was
saying she's tired of this separation of
church and state stuff we looked at this
about a month ago when it took place the
reason we had so many over reaching
regulations in our nation is because the
church
complied
the church is supposed to direct the
government the government is not
supposed to direct the church that is
not how our founding fathers intended it
and i'm tired of this separation of
church and state junk that's not in the
constitution it was in a stinking letter
and it means nothing like what they say
it does now i've told you before
that she's wrong in fact when they say
it was in a stinkin letter what they're
trying to do is minimize the idea the
desire for separation of church and
state to like an offhanded casual letter
written by thomas jefferson that's what
lauren bobert wants you to believe she
wants you to believe it's all mis it's
all a big mistake there was no actual
desire for separation of church and
state thomas jefferson sort of mentioned
it in one letter and that's it but the
reality is that were they deists or not
were they christians or not
the founding fathers very clearly
recognized and it's established in the
constitution
that there should be no prioritization
of one religion over another nor of
religion over non-religion in the united
states it's abundantly clear the fact
that we're going back to that you know
we one of the things republicans love to
do is they don't just want to go back to
the 1950s they also want to go back to
debates that have been long settled and
that
anybody who takes them seriously
realizes there actually is no debate
about um and this is extraordinarily
dangerous so we're going to talk
tomorrow on the on the show
uh about the decidedly christian
nationalist move of the republican party
not everybody in the republican party
agrees with it i mean someone like adam
kinzinger he doesn't agree with it he's
also retiring and is kind of
increasingly irrelevant within the party
but even trump now is regularly at his
rallies and we might look at the clip
later saying we we kneel only before god
and all of these different sort of
signals to the christian nationalists so
this is a very dangerous movement in
particular because if they do well in
november and then they control the 2024
election there are all sorts of ways in
which they can impose this christianity
in the public square completely
antithetical
i mean without a doubt completely
antithetical to what the framers wanted
so we will talk about it more and in the
meantime you can send me your thoughts
by finding me on twitter at deepakman